hey everybody and welcome to the latest
episode of the Shan method the show or I
do silly things in video games I'm Sean
McGinnis this is chris waters I'm like
the Sun show to your Don Quijote that is
probably that you do all the crazy crap
and I try to keep you from murdering
yourself and exposing yourself to the
general public in honor of the winter
olympics happening in Sochi right now I
would try to do my best to perform feats
of athleticism within a different world
you start on one end of the freeway and
you attempt to run like hell to the
other end of the freeway the only thing
is that you have to make sure the camera
is pulled in as tight as possible you
can look you can't look it's not Frogger
in the sense that you're actively trying
to avoid cars it's like Russian Roulette
meets Frogger yeah so yeah you just you
just start you ready for this yeah here
we go let's go nobody's Bastiaan wrap
folks he's made half way through
oncoming traffic oh who closed missed
there and he's all the way across he's
halfway across oh he just made it about
sixty percent of the way two lanes into
the other side alright and I can keep
continuing these games oh oh he's get it
he's got two hits down the judges are
gonna fault him for that that's a full
rag doll that's gonna take off the
points it's gonna be tough yes the flop
button is the greatest innovation in
gaming history it's great arguably it's
if you're playing the 360 version as I
am you press be in midair and your body
goes limp this car oh look oh look these
guys look hella floppity flops oh yeah
sorry ol limp body tackle haha come back
way back great is this yeah but no I
don't know if I'm ready are you ready
for this I check out and confused about
what you're gonna do check out these
dudes on the bench hey guys oh yo did
you just kill them both yeah wow yeah
who's too now I
walk away like a baller the Skyfall
cheat GTA 5 that basically sends you up
into the air and you skydive to the
ground what I'm gonna try to do you land
in somebody's backyard swimming pool all
right here we go vomiting from all that
tomorrow in a serious freeway situation
sure I want to get I want to go to
Hollywood Hollywood is where all them
swimming roses are that looks like a
good swim now looks like an athletic
that looks like I can do it Oh guys
going right come on not make it oh I'll
live hey um do on the swimming window
into the golf course might have bodies
of water I see a good sized swimming
there's a little yep there's oh there's
their Warner everything I can make this
one dive hard for it not uh all right
i'm gonna try to land in this golf club
looks pretty solid looks good i could
get a half oh look at that in all right
sizable golf course type pond swimming
out of it knife and hand yep just we say
that dab what if you were a golfer and
you're just hanging out here and doing
your thing i'll send a man literally
clausal splash a man literally falls
from the sky and emerges soaking wet
fully clothed with a knife in time for
this one go hard nope oh so hard i'm
gonna make also hard to make it no no
pull up Bosh glancing blow I see a pool
I see you're going over that one going
for the no poet not a pool tennis court
tennis court you turn our queue turn go
back I turn Hills these are small pools
high degree of difficulty oh so close in
the clothes I want Lex zero margin
alright I see one over there there try
to kiss me you gotta dive now start
diving now yeah now pull up slightly oh
the roof wow that was like your most
Placid landing yeah that's pretty good
right I feel like I could do it from
this rooftop sure I mean but you have to
do a rag doll if do rag doll non-stop
double double backflip
Oh an umbrella let's see if I can do it
from here Oh shallow Inge so now i have
two skyfall my way up there yeah what's
my parachute button quick parachute
button you'll never find out enough of
that I'm gonna I'm gonna count on not
dying here glancing blow oh you go ahead
up you're going all the way down we're
good you are Oh [ __ ] he'll awake who
are you going a dirt bike hunting eat it
yeah cuckoo cuckoo [ __ ] congratulations
Sean you've made it to lookout point
here on the top of this mountain uh what
are you gonna do what words you have for
the folks at home oh and it's a race
between the tours going ahead oh I
always liked both gonna make it down
into the ditch who which one of them is
going to stand up it looks like my walk
away from the live I think I won that
way oh yes I did maybe not so much that
is why you never go stand near the edge
of something that's nice oh look who's
look who's back what wait a minute hold
on hold the phone that's what he's doing
literally this cannot be you're an
abomination of nature I will not have
zombies patrol you were dead you
wouldn't dead nothin so you shall remain
can you go over can you go over there to
where the tourists is and Menace them
with a knife into falling off I could
probably do it Trott don't fall off
yourself though please just like do a
stab near that person that was close oh
no evidence it's the perfect ride buddy
it is the perfect crime look at that guy
go home they're on the phone what is she
doing what is happening here Wow people
are staring intently at their wrists oh
you are such a gentle lover non
discriminating Oh
she'd ahead Shh she may pass out come on
get on top are you presenting to that
man what oh no I would hire was tender
all right so the challenge is to bike
all the way down the mountain while
while still living is that the idea stay
on your bike all the way down the
mountain I feel like that's probably and
I think you can start it off how much it
is which direction do i go obviously you
start in the direction where there are
high KIRs that you can plow through
because they are the starting gates okay
dude dude and ease off folks right
through the lemonade down he's got a big
obstacle right out of him she just
called you [ __ ] Jesus that is my
nickname please don't please don't Oh
will you ride your bike in there already
oh no she actually did call the cops I
feel like I just got to go for it you
ride into the sunset oh here we go and
shaunas off he's gonna hit the same
rocky did last time Oh an arrow miss
their narrow miss of another rock and oh
yeah this is looking good oh yeah hard
rare going down I'm here Randy oh I got
a beautifui with ag angle adjust this is
gonna be a hard off and he's up again
riding straight downhill looks like it's
smooth sailing here he's actually
pedaling to gain some more momentum you
can never have too much speed when just
bombing down a giant mountain I wish I
had my lights growing larger below with
every passing moment I think you need to
ride out onto that promontory by that
rock and I'm really shocked yep just
really get get into it finish strong
coming up on to finish here [ __ ] here we
go historic run down the mountain yeah
and he's gonna smash right into this
container nope we're good that one nope
new defense No nope did I hear a train
maybe go get into sprint mode the train
is no God rapidly rope mode all right
can I do this I think
need to switch it to the reverse camera
right now it's so close ah oh god oh god
oh yeah the light now or the charge now
gently shoved by the guiding me what's
up for the Shan method next week I don't
know yet you guys suggest something in
the comments yeah if you guys have any
ideas suggest it a game where you can
goof around and go crazy always ideal
for the show or right here at Shawn
mcinnes on the tweet tweet me at s
McInnis um that's Chris waters yeah I'm
Sean thanks for watching and we'll see
you guys next Wednesday